We rarely get a data set
that's just perfect for
the analysis we're trying to do.
In this section, we're going to cover
the concepts of what an analyst needs to
do when faced with missing data
as they prepare their data for
an analytic process.
So, early in the lesson,
we saw issues revolving around
what we call dirty data.
Another issue is that sometimes
there are data elements
that just aren't there.
In this case, for
whatever reason, we're dealing with
records that have gaps in the data.
Before we start going over
these concepts, though,
let's take a look at what we're really
talking about when we say missing data,
and some of the forms it
can take in our data sets.